carry out of the best scripts that
you've read in your life and of those
that have been made into films on
average how long has it been between the
time that you read the script and the
time that the movie came out and came to
fruition oh gosh
a long time from the time that I've held
a script in my hand whether I'm the
producer and I put it on the big screen
or someone else's it was someone else's
child to raise the the length of stay
between script and an actual produced
film varies so dramatically and it's not
necessarily based on budget but but
there are so many it's one of the most
collaborative media one can imagine you
know if I'm a fine artist I can paint a
painting without permission today but if
I want to make a film and I want to make
a film for let's say a million dollars
or 100 million dollars or five hundred
thousand dollars I need a lot of inputs
and I need a lot of preparation my films
the fastest I actually did several films
what I consider to be a breakneck pace
which was three years from script to
screen pretty woman was three years
under siege was three years
there was there was a couple of Indies
that were less and some studio films
that were longer but but there is no
there is no proper standard every film
dies a thousand deaths some of them are
deaths by paper cuts and some are death
by massive train wrecks and then you
resuscitate you move on and and and you
know Forrest Gump reportedly was I don't
know 13 or 15 years between scripting
the screen so you never there's no
there's no rule what is the best way for
a writer to make a living as a writer in
today's age 2017 and we rewrite you know
look the best way for if I were a writer
today I were entering the business today
or I were in the business today as a
writer as a professional writer I think
there are several things assuming you
know listen if your David Kelly and you
have that level of success you already
know your path but if you're not yet
David Kelly or you're not yet the
equivalent of that on the feature films
on whatever that might be if you don't
have that little trophy on your shelf I
think one of the great things you can do
for yourself is to be more diversified I
know that that's probably contrary to
old-school thinking which is specialized
become the best at one thing and known
for one thing but I think we are all
today brands each and every one of us is
brand building and to the extent that we
can that involves audiences involves
public it involves our colleagues in the
business and so if you happen to be a
writer and you want to do TV and film
that's okay if you want to do you know
apart from TV and film if you want to be
writing a blog that's okay if you want
to be looking at creating alternative
content or let's just say a TV serie a
Twitter I won't use the word TV if you
want to create a series on YouTube I
absolutely applaud it because today the
rules are out the window and people are
looking for
their talent in every conceivable corner
every nook and cranny and a lot of that
is social media a lot of it is the
unexpected and and the same is true in
Reverse if you're selling ideas you're
no longer limited to selling the ABC CBS
or NBC or on the future side to
Paramount Warner Disney Universal etc
you have all of these other sort of
counterculture approaches or or the new
Hollywood if you will and it's Hulu and
it's Amazon it's Netflix and it's it's
it's red box and it's all these other
companies that have real meat on the
bone real distribution real capital and
and and then brands you know there's all
these relationships with brand driven
stuff on on social platforms so I think
the key question is not is is to
understand who you are is a greater
where you properly can succeed where you
are excited and where you think your
audience lives and consider those
alternatives to while you're writing
your Oscar candidate of a screenplay or
whatever that thing is
you